you burst onto the music scene you you
know and like pop stars do you burn
really brightly and then as these things
do you know it drifted away you went off
to Miami and we kind of knew you were in
Miami and and then when you came back
you were so instantly cool again like
which was like the world decided Craig
David cool again I mean how did that
happen do you know what was I mean Miami
was I mean was great for me for the
period of time I was there
and I was throwing a house party there
which was in your house in my house they
start off as like a 10 people free
drinks before you went out nice and easy
couple of couple shots some oh good and
then it kind of word of mouth spread and
people were like oh can I come to tears
five and they were texting their mates
kind of comes to tears five and I just
sort of built to the point where I was
that I was playing to like nearly a
hundred people in my home which was you
think it was strange but actually was
everyone respected it like it was my
home but there was a moment where I
remember we'd had a couple of drinks
anyway and I'm playing with music I'm on
the mic it wasn't a good time drinks on
tap food there I'm like a cop over there
over there and I'm like I can't be it
must be the drink giving me a little bit
waved so I just carried on like playing
thought nothing of it following days it
was new house I was like no I thought
was a drink so that was it was just
crazy to go from like 10 people were my
mates yeah it certainly not so where do
you you ran a house party and in way
Alan what you you've done a sort of
house party but turned it into a thing
sort of like I had I had a dressing room
I had a place of a party in my dressing
room and I called it club coming
no actually the bar in New York coke
upcoming labor union I have but you have
not been on of Caprio but you have had
big names asses yes yes yes yeah I think
the story you're referring to is one
time when Adele and Jennifer Lawrence
came and they were having a good time
and they went downstairs and was a drag
queen on that night hosting a thing and
they went downstairs into the basement
the very unglamorous basement where the
dancers get changed and the drag queens
you think and it's all creates a beer
and things and that and they were down
there and and a video and Jennifer
Lawrence getting her makeup done by a
drag queen and I she's doing this Adair
that we both had a few and Adele cons
are in the corner goes chase the [ __ ]
face of Dior
[Laughter]
[Music]
you